last time I picked Jabba as a player
tomorrow who I thought of as a 21st
century player and you know he's a very
extreme version I would say this time I
decided to choose a Caro who I would say
is oh you know I'm probably a little bit
stronger than Java but also you know he
kind of his style is naturally very very
aggressive he tends to take lots of
risks and I don't know I mean I'd say
that his style is kind of hard to define
like most of the top guys up but I would
say that he's definitely ok playing you
know with lots of risks not even
necessarily playing always the best
moves but he's very good at certain
things like he's very good at presenting
problems for his opponents to solve he's
very resourceful and he also is very
opportunistic so if you give him any
sort of chance to take advantage of
something he'll almost always be ready
to jump on it and it's one of the things
I wanted to focus on yeah so this
position is kind of weird like I'm not
exactly sure how to evaluate it what do
you guys think
I don't think this is an example of a
bad position but as I said I think it's
actually very difficult to evaluate this
position tell me why you know white
might try to play on the Kings side but
then the Queen's that might become weak
these are things that are true but okay
I think the important things are blacks
King that definitely matters why what is
wrong with blacks King what do you mean
g6 and h5 are still there as far as I
know true if the pawn we're back on h7 I
would like blacks position more I think
we could all agree with that right
Black's a little overextended there so
that King is always going to be a little
bit open but why is black not just
busted usually if your Kings open it's
Sicilian your positions horrible right
what is what does black have in his
favor the knight on e5 in general in
Sicilians if black can secure a piece so
well on the e5 square usually a knight
it's very problematic because the knight
there not only defends the Kings side
which is a little bit weak but it also
controls all the important squares it
hits the bishop on d3 so if you ever
want to get rid of that Bishop you can
it threatens Knight c4 it holds a lot of
crucial squares and it just basically
makes it so that it's really difficult
for white to do anything with that
Knight there and I think because of this
the position may even be roughly
balanced but okay and as one of the
things I've noted is that with the karo
he doesn't always care whether he's
better or not now sometimes this can be
just like if not an advantage he can
sometimes you know play into positions
which aren't so great for him and get
punished but a lot of the times I think
it actually helps him out because he's
far less restricted he's not bound so
much by trying to find always the
absolute best moves he's just you know
he wants a kind of complicated position
he likes complicated positions but he's
also you know he doesn't always
whether he's better or not he just wants
to play moves and you know create
problems for his opponents so how can
white improve his position for those of
you who have not seen the game for those
of you who have seen it I think you can
come up with something all right
so how can white improve the position
I'm not asking for a huge sacrifice or
some dramatic small improvement I think
that's a very good idea the question is
which Knight do you start with and I and
I honestly think that it could very well
be that both moves are okay
he ended up starting with 92 the reason
I like this move is because in the
beginning of the game this Knight makes
perfect sense right you're controlling
the central squares you're controlling
the e4 pawn but now this pawns defended
way more than enough times right you got
three defenders in one attacker this
pawn does not need to be defended by
that night but this Knight is also
restricted right it's can't move here it
can't move here so this Knight often
ends up being kind of misplaced later in
the game in a Sicilian so usually you
move it there early because it looks
nice and this happens to lots of pieces
and lots of openings where at first you
put a piece on a really good square but
as the game progresses your opponent
controls the squares that can move - it
becomes not such a good square you have
to fix it so he played 90 - so where's
that Knight headed most likely very good
all right
so black played rookie 8 he doesn't want
to give up his pawn on e6 white
continues with the plan so he wasn't
really worried about Knight takes D 3
moves mainly because it gives up all
defense of the King side so what do you
think blacks should play here
it's an excellent wolf pins the night to
the Queen
okay the Queen can move to g3 for
instance and then you have to calculate
lines like Bishop takes out for Queen
tonight takes d3 and e5 but maybe your
Kings to open probably is so maybe you
just play a move like you still have to
be careful like what do you play after
Queen g3
teenage sevens possible but you have to
calculate sacrifices like taking on g6
right I don't think it works
but yeah King age seven looks reasonable
I also am not convinced this is so bad
because you can take take
I guess maybe there's this move that
that is probably oh no wait
of course whoops good thing I wasn't
playing this game but pawn takes Knight
e5 Queen h6 and now you're not obligated
to take the bishop you could move back
and actually this position might be
pretty good for black because here this
night is really awkward Queen could come
into c2 probably not so bad
okay blacks it like doesn't have to play
Queen d3 for example rook f1 was
probably a reasonable move but the point
is blacks totally in the game it's just
a normal position instead black decided
that his Queen was out of play on the
Queen side and he wanted to bring it to
the King side played this but so for
those of you who have not seen the game
whatever why it's options well what
moves do you look at first every
position
well what temple moves are possible just
list them
Knight takes c6 Knight takes h5 any of
those Queen g3 is the temple move taking
on e5 of course so many of those look
promising okay
so believe it or not black resigned here
question is why did black now
resignation was a little premature but
he did you know it is a losing position
most likely the question is why why does
this work
it looks like Blackwell the position was
normal just to move ago right black and
played Bishop h6 would be totally normal
and this is actually one of the reasons
why Bishop h6 was a good move because
you prevent this move and this is a
serious problem because the Knights
pinned and it doesn't have a good
defense
if King f7 Rock f1 is a little bit more
precise King has nowhere to run to guard
this Knight
if King here incidentally you probably
are gonna play check it's not made that
I can block but you can take here take
the Queen you can do lots of wonderful
things now for someone who is not under
the age of 16 what is the move here
thank you b5 the bishop pins the night
and there's no way to defend it then I
can take but you simply take this Knight
and notice again the pin is just too
much so it seems like kind of a sudden
end to a normal game right but I think
that and okay black clearly blundered
black was a pretty strong GM I mean it's
not like he normally would make a
mistake like this but one of the things
that a car was very good at is he knows
kind of how to put pressure and he's
always looking for traps now he didn't
play for just a trick he didn't you know
put some piece on a weird square just to
play for one little trick he improved
his piece right but he improved the
peace knowing that this trick was there
and he's very good at pouncing on
opportunities when his opponents don't
quite see what he's up to
so yes 92 to f4 is just a nice
improvement for the night there was no
real mystery right it looked like just
normal moves but Knight takes g6 was a
definite problem and it wasn't one that
black spotted
time again having to resign after one
move is kind of sad but the way it goes
alright so the next one so yeah this was
his next this is another game of his
from the Olympiad so in the opening he
actually had a lot less space than his
opponent but he snagged the two bishops
so it's kind of a common you know I
would almost say what openings does this
look like for reverse colors almost
what's structure always looking for the
structures right remember how for those
of you are here for the previous lecture
the Benoni structure I'm always looking
for the structure maroc see bind is with
E for c4 pawns against on and on d6
usually this is like a French imagine if
black has a pawn here it's like a French
with colors reversed and you'll notice
this like when GM's talk about positions
like we're always looking what structure
is this what opening is this because it
usually tells us where our pieces belong
and what's going on it's a little
different because white has a dark
square Bishop and black does not I'd say
this is a very important feature despite
the fact that black has extra piece I
would probably not want to be black here
for the main reason that I don't like
not having my bishop in a position where
my pawns usually want to go on light
squares right I do not want pawns on
light squares and not to have a dark
square bishop in general so I would
already prefer white but it's nothing
serious he played a five to try to
discourage expansion over here but a
Carl plays patiently Bishop here you can
tell he has his eye on this but again
most most GM's will not allow you to
checkmate them on g7 at least not right
away
keeps pieces out of g4 so for example
after a move like this he didn't want to
have to deal with this bishop trade
because he wants to keep his two bishops
and you'll notice this is true in most
situations if you have two bishops it's
nice to keep your two bishops even a
trade of bishops makes it so that
your life is a little bit more tricky so
he didn't want that d5a four so this
part of the game I'm gonna go through a
little quicker b6 notice how normally
you wouldn't want to create this week's
square in a position like this right but
why is this now not such a bad option
what feature in the position allows this
to be okay right
then the main feature is that because
white has this bishop in black does not
white doesn't have to worry so much
about the dark squares becoming weak
right because White's the one with the
dark square bishop and that's why he can
get away with this kind of thing and
notice how this bishop becomes very
active on the a3 square yes the bishop
will be nice if this ever opened but do
you think it's gonna happen anytime soon
I don't think so so he wants activate
his bishop this way so this happens he
activates his bishop finishes his
development he maneuvers his knight to
g3 which actually I'm not so sure about
but my guess would be that he didn't
want to get attacked over here maybe
because the it looks like the Queen
sides where the actions happening so I
was a little surprised by this move but
okay he decides to put his knight FG
three castles brings his rook he's not
really worried about h4 because then I
can always come back and now he builds
his position and now this is the part of
the game where I'd really like to start
because he plays rook c2 preparing just
to double rooks and then eventually try
to take over the c5 and black decides to
mix up the game with b5 now if it were
me I would probably not want to deal
with this I probably would have played
Queen d2 on my last move why would I
want my opponent to be able to play b5
one of the features of a carros game is
that he does not mind his opponent
complicated the game even if he's better
he often just likes complications he
almost wants to tempt his opponent to go
into them because he's so confident he
can calculate them better than his
opponent that isn't to say if he's
totally winning he's gonna
kind of play every time that would make
him not such a strong chess player and
he's a very strong chess player the key
is that he will doesn't mind allowing
complications as long as he thinks
they're decent for him and he also you
know thinks he hasn't covered better
than his opponent does cuz b5 could be a
really nasty move if you don't expect it
right all of a sudden if the pawn lens
on b4 your bishops not as good you know
it might grab the C file for black if
you're not ready to to deal with it so
the question is how does he deal with
this move so let's use process of
elimination a little bit what move do we
not want to allow under any
circumstances so how can we prevent b4
that's possible but that would also give
up c4 right so let's find a less drastic
solution to our problems Bishop d6 is
possible but the bishop doesn't have
that many squares right so I would be a
little bit nervous not to mention that
you have to watch out for for example B
take C B take C 96 right attacking the
bishop the knight might head to c4 I
don't think that's something you want to
allow probably that make sense
remember Takara right he likes to solve
his problems tactically
and in this case there's a very good
reason to solve them tactically
some see takes I like I do not like
giving up that Bishop especially I don't
like allowing b4 and then trades this
guy and then this guy's loose I'd say
that's not what he wants to do but he
simply goes back I know this is kind of
a letdown after such a pause right but
what's the idea of this
right yeah there's a pin on the bishop
it's that simple
and he thinks that b5 while an active
move also created weaknesses now this is
weak now this is weak there's a pin so
he thought that he actually was
provoking his opponent a little bit to
play b5 in order to give him some
weaknesses this is something else I've
noticed he likes to do more so than a
lot of chess players he likes to provoke
his opponent into advancing or into
making things complicated a little bit
and in this case I mean he kind of has a
point because those two pawns look very
weak so black took and played Queen b8
trying to defend
why played this move so again being
tricky right because this bishop is not
defended he can try to attack this pawn
and it's kind of an annoying thing so in
this position black played h4 which I
actually think is a poor move because
after h4 night f1 I think the Knights
improved a little bit this was the move
I expected and here black white actually
can do something which is quite good
so of course you take bishop ticks so
the question is what's the idea here so
take out any five runs into what
followed by
do you want to trade all the bombs
because it makes it more garish right so
does anyone remember the rule I gave you
at the beginning of this game
regarding bishops yes when you have a
bishop pair you want to keep it bishop
d1 looks like kind of a silly move right
you're putting your bishop on a like a
weird square to avoid the trade but
sometimes moves like this are actually
very strong and I think that's the case
here because now not only are you
avoiding the bishop trade that's only
part of it part of the deal is that now
you're defending your one weakness on
the Queen side but what what pawn will
be much tougher to defend for black
eighty-five is gonna be extremely weak
here the bishop can maybe maneuver via B
2 and C 3 the knight can come back via
e2 and go either to f4 or to c3
basically Black's gonna be tied to
defending this a pawn and life is not
gonna be so pleasant so Bishop d1 would
have been a really nice move and again I
think he would have spotted it but but
yeah it's basically it really
illustrates the point that when you have
just one side of the board where there
are weaknesses you want to make sure
that your weaknesses are defended while
you can attack their opponents and
avoiding the bishop trade really does
that because note how this Bishop okay
can go here but it doesn't do anything
there and it can't really attack this
palm right
this pawn can't be attacked by this
bishop
so h4 was played instead and then Ricky
six but now he can grab this pawn quite
safely so pawn takes pawn Bishop takes
Queen eight this was the defense that
Audubon was relying on and I actually
know I played him at this tournament the
Netherlands we analyzed a bunch
tactically the guy is very very strong
and this was back when he was say lower
rated GM now the guys you know
approaching 2700 is probably going to be
an elite GM at some point but tactically
he calculates very fast and very
accurately but when you're you have one
guy who's approaching twenty six hundred
playing a guy or sorry approaching 2,700
compared to a guys for approaching 2,800
there's still a level death
and while Audubon calculates extremely
well I still wouldn't take him over a
car on that one and my guess would be
that Carlos simply I've calculated him
in this position but the key is what
deta Carlos see that maybe Audubon
amidst because this was clearly blacks
defense this was the idea to be able to
pin this bishop and win it if Queen
takes a four rook takes a six the game
becomes very messy right even though
you're up to pawn you have a pin Bishop
life is not so pleasant so what was your
Carlos idea
and also keep in mind that if during the
game you have to see this quite a ways
in advance because all these moves were
pretty forceful well let's make this
easier black start is what with with the
rook right prevent this move
huh it was a good thought this move is
possible but after takes here a three
black kind of hangs on it's not over yet
because this pawn is actually slightly
annoying you've given up your light
square bishop it's not so easy this move
is very clever because now if rook takes
Bishop you just take on a four and
you're up a very very clean pawn because
you control all the Queen side squares
if you allow rook takes a six then black
controls the a file it becomes much more
complicated
so quite a move right hanging one bishop
to save the other but black decided to
take this pawn instead and this is a
very very common idea when a side is
thinks they're losing he could have
taken on d6 and allowed to karo to take
on a4 and then just be a clean pawn up
but he thought okay I'm the kind of
techniques good enough he's just gonna
beat me so what I want to do is I want
to make a slight mess of the game I want
to keep the game complicated to give
black a chance to let me back in it so
what not
keep in mind that now whites under more
pressure what right if white doesn't win
any material here and allows the bishop
to get taken back you're not going to be
up anything so white has to be very
precise
good start you played a tree I think the
moves are actually equivalent I think
the purpose of Queen III though is to
make it so this bishop could move after
Queen before this bishop candles so
maybe a move like 98 will be possible
not totally sure but I think that Queen
a3 makes it a little bit nicer but okay
b2 also now the rook does have the
option of moving so it's usually good to
find squares which defend all your guys
the Queen here just defends this this
this well if route b1 what's the problem
that white has not the Queen's a bit
overloaded and also these bishops can't
move right this one certainly can
maybe this one
but you have a better one
so the idea of Bishop e5 is that because
your queen on a it hangs you allow me to
get out right so what was your idea can
i still move my bishop
I assume that say yes this tongue
sticking out usually means yes
so what else prevent this resource of
Bishop b5
you're very cautious tone as appreciated
but yes Queens these Knicks if this
bishop moves this one hangs so that's
the skewer of death right there the
skewer and an x-ray it's nice when
contact is combined they they're very
picturesque anyway it's very depressing
for white because one of the bishops has
to fall and with that probably the
advantage and that's why a karo to
convey to but think about this not only
to give you an idea of the level that
these guys are at not only do all these
moves have to be correct now because
this whole sequence is forced he was
probably thinking about this over five
moons ago so five moves back or maybe
more he had to think about this whole
sequence before he went down it now it
doesn't mean he didn't keep calculated
it with no errors but it means that
those are the kind of calculations you
have to make and both these guys are
extremely strong calculators so they can
actually do this but even guys like this
can make mistakes and often what it
means is one guy sees a little bit more
accurately or one move deeper and that
makes the whole difference in the line
and these are the kind of battles that
it Carl likes because he tends to win
them because he calculates so well so he
takes some v2 rook takes d6 but black
has even material how how is why it's
supposed to win
uh-huh
this should be six I can play rugby see
Bishop c6 I can play Knight takes not
yet after Bishop c6 rook takes rook
takes rook c8 keep in mind also that
even if I sack a queen for a look and a
piece it's not entirely clear you're
gonna win you probably will but it's not
totally sure right
the ship c8 is very cute but the problem
is I can move my knife down or play the
pieces sometimes that you can't win a
piece you know sometimes all you can win
as a pond and it's funny because he gave
up a pond to win this pawn but this is a
very very important part because now he
four is really weak not to mention that
I would say blacks King is not ideal but
okay you still not done yet rook b6
and the night comes to g2 he's safe
notice how if black had not played h4
with the night on g3 black might have
had more chances to do something here
but because he played a move forcing the
night to a better Square and it's hard
to believe that f1 will be better than
g3 but the net on d2 is actually a
pretty good piece so you can get why I
was a little confused while Carl put it
on g3 in the first place but it's a
little too deep for me
so Bishop to b3 and then here he was
able to win pretty smoothly so black
played King g7 so the key to a position
like this is okay you're up upon you
probably should be winning because black
also has weaknesses the f7 pawns kind of
week d4 pawn White's pieces are a little
better the key is to make sure you
always are maximizing your pressure and
not giving it up for example if you have
an attack or you have a lot of pressure
involving the Queen's
you don't really want to trade them even
though trading Queens often you know
will give you an endgame which usually
you want to trade pieces when you're
ahead right but if you have an attacker
you have pressure you don't want to give
up one of your good pieces for your
opponent's bad pieces so I think in this
game you used a pretty good combination
of you know keeping up the pressure
while not allowing conflict even someone
who likes complications like a car does
he's not going to allow some you know
insanity for the most part when he's
just waiting and in this position rather
than being better he's probably just
winning so he doesn't want to allow too
much so and again these positions there
are lots of different moves
he plays Queen c3 he doesn't want to be
in a pin for longer than he has to Queen
d7 brings us Knight into the game all
pretty logical right group to c6
he pins himself although in this case
that bishops pretty well defended and
okay next move he can think about
playing Queen a5 or Queen b3 and trying
to attack them so the knight got off the
back rank
okay seven
so notice how he's kind of just
improving and taking his time
so the rook on a7 is just a slight
improvement pins the knight there's some
pressure along that that the seventh
rank just kind of an annoying thing so
black played rugby six white played rook
Bishop b3 again very very small
improvements but now the Queen can maybe
move to c7 the bishop might go to c2 to
attack the pawn the rook on d6 can no
longer come into the game there's small
improvements to the position black
played 26
so
what to do
and keep in mind there might not be more
than one good news
so what's the tempting move Nancy for
but what's the problem
maybe well Brooksie six I'll take on d6
and take on up some
I don't think it works
if 94 yeah Brooksie six I think this
works out you'll find that when your
position is good tactics tend to be in
your favor I don't believe this works I
could play a 98 check but I think even
meaner is this one and then rook takes
actually I don't know if I take this
because now that was a little bit of a
loud whistle there and now there's made
threats and okay so probably you should
play an idea check after all if King
takes yeah after after 98 the same idea
so again tactics tend to work in your
favor but here I think that black has it
has maybe Queen before as an option
which might be more annoying
there's also Queen c6 but then d5 might
be might be quite strong again he wants
to keep things kind of simple right so
he plays Queen c4 this pawn should
probably be defended he plays Queen f8
and now what happens if Knight takes e4
because you always want to be on the
lookout for tactics right curious thing
could be ripped before is that it's now
you're tied to this Queen Queen see to
it Queen B it could be because now the
problem is that rook takes here and
you're threatening mate so remember that
these guys are these guys are both very
very strong tactically so they're always
looking for traps that's a pretty nasty
trap wouldn't you say so you always have
to be very careful you know your
opponent looks like you have an easy way
to win make sure you check the tactics
and all the forcing last night take c4
you can see that rook before is a temple
move you have to calculate it
Queen b8 also a temple move because it
attacks like everything and potentially
threatens me so you have to be very very
cautious and that's why almost for sure
white played rook to c7 just sort of
improving his rook may be threatening
rook c8 black played rook before white
moved the Queen a six so just kind of
keeping blacks Queen from coming to d6
from improving itself so black played
back white played Queen back so my guess
would be that he was trying to gain a
little time and by the way if you for
example let's say he played Queen to a6
and this is a good lesson regardless of
whether you're winning or losing
if after rook back you decide wait a
second I don't want my Queen there I'm
gonna go back there's nothing wrong with
that don't do it again because it means
that you'll have a lot of Perpetual and
then you have to be depressed slowing
you drew a one game but repeating the
position once is something GM's do all
the time and we do it off and on purpose
first of all it actually can mess with
the head of some people because they're
like oh why is my opponent going back
and forth do I want to draw what's going
on and meanwhile we're just thinking
about what we're gonna do next so
repeating doesn't mean you're going to
repeat more than once so repeating once
is totally fun and often times and
actually it happened here
repeating once makes your opponent's
second
himself I feel like they should improve
their position and oftentimes they play
a bad move to avoid the repetition
Audubon could have gone back but he was
like but then white I'll just play Queen
c3 for example and improve his pieces
and I wouldn't have accomplished
anything I'm gonna try to punish him for
going back and I'll play this move
however what's the problem
now it works so he took and the problem
is night takes up two fails
well which one queen takes is actually
very important because if you take with
the rook and this would by the way was
almost certainly autobahns his idea now
you kind of a little embarrassed now
maybe it's still winning after I move
like g4 but do you want to allow crazy
complications like this when you're
totally won I don't think so but you
take with Queen and that ends the debate
because now the king can't just move
away cuz this will hang with cheque so
you have to take and now the night line
so there will be no checkmate without
that name and definitely don't allow a
knight into here so notice how you know
he's these guys are always looking for
tricks and and and trying to you know
improve their positions but you also
have to be on the lookout for tactic in
the details all the time so it's very
important that Queen takes f7 is
available he played King h6 instead
which is kind of tricky but now you
displace here which is a nice move
because now ninety five to fails to what
yeah and from here on it was pretty
simple played Knight g5 incidentally any
chance you have to tie your opponent up
usually makes the wind very easy and it
also makes it easier on you right
because if your opponent has almost no
moves you there there are fewer chances
you're gonna miss something if you give
your opponent lots of options maybe one
of them will be good right so it's funny
there there are some positions where you
want to give your opponent options
because they can mess it up but often
when you have a one position you want to
give your opponent very few options
Queen here is a very nasty move because
it hits this pawn hits this guy and just
ties will block top of completely so we
played here he grabbed another pawn
because why not Queen here and then okay
there are many moves to win
he chose kind of a nice move which is
this one the idea being that now if the
Queen takes the bishop you have mate if
Queen b1 you also have mate so he has to
trade but this this end game is not
salvageable
and he just sent three pawns against the
super GM is usually too much so that was
that as far as this game goes but note
how you know okay he he got a slightly
better position from the opening at
least in my opinion but the way he won
was he kind of led his opponent you know
come to him he didn't actually feel the
need to just brush after his opponent he
built his position a little bit and the
second his opponent is shaded tactics
with b5 he just said well I'm just gonna
I'll calculate you he grabbed upon
wanting you to he calculated the long
sequence very well but that was the main
difference between them this game and he
simply calculated a little bit better a
little bit deeper